welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
show you the games you want to see every
day at 2:00 and 7:00 p.m. Pacific so you
can make your own decisions fortnight is
going to early access on July 25th and
this is the game two opening moments I
have to be honest I never thought I'd be
talking about building battle in a post
Starhawk era but here we are and I still
think the concept is fun we're gonna
pull the devs in for a launch week
stream so give us the old thumbs up and
subscribe to get notified when that
happens and don't forget to contribute
some good questions in the comments
below let's get to it
you can hear me and I need your help out
here maybe ready air meter
[Music]
[Music]
you're awake how's your head okay those
stairs are really meant for feet just a
tip for moving forward
[Music]
introductions I'm right drill is any
indication we won't last a second in
this dorm on our own well that certainly
explains sponsors fun fact our mission
was to prevent the storm from happening
so oh I think you just found our plan B
here read you loud and clear
we have survivors in danger the storms
closing in please let's cut to the chase
have you ever considered fighting the
forces of evil because we really need a
commander and I think you've got what it
takes
don't listen to him you're going to be
amazing spirit connecting you to our
demander now guys take your positions
[Music]
switch
whatever you ready commander okay
commander Ramirez is counting on you to
get those survivors to safety hello ray
if you can hear me now would be a great
time to hurry up
copy that weapons and building systems
coming online now yeah back in action
we got a pack of hugs dead ahead what's
our firepower situation see for yourself
[Music]
lead the way commander
[Music]
that's how it's done commander
all right everything we need to craft a
gun open the inventory click on the gun
icon select it and cracked
mark the location of the force on your
map let's go protect those survivors
hurried up up there Ramirez
take out those hot
so we lost you you're not that lucky
what's your status
we can't find a way out of here soon
well that's good as dead no need to
worry we've got your back
let's play some traps to keep hostels
from getting inside place tracks in
front of the door those traps buy us
some time let's see how those survivors
are holding up
[Music]
[Music]
Ramirez king-type we're gonna take care
of it
[Music]
[Music]
Ramirez I'm getting some seriously weird
readings here what's on the other side
of that wall I can fix that enter edit
mode select the square in the middle and
the square below it to create a door
[Music]
nice work
whoa was this here the whole time is
this a missile or some sort of rocket
some sort of rocket actually wait it's
the best sort of rocket commander
there's a satellite on board if we have
a satellite we can guide Ramirez and the
survivors back to our home base then
let's launch this thing
[Music]
[Music]
great now get outside before you're
engulfed in flaming rocket exhaust
we need to keep that rocket safe until
watch another way it's coming I need
some backup don't take any chances Lenny
I'm on my way I think I could all be
we've got more incoming you need to
protect the survivor
purport the danger
we're working on something before
air strike is coming online ten seconds
air strike when you're ready commander
you've been old now
10 seconds to blast-off
[Music]
standby to move Ramirez as soon as that
satellite data is ready we're bringing
you in I can't believe it
people are still alive out there and we
can save them this could be our thing
where we start oh I get it
I have people I'm looking for to look so
what if they're storms and monsters if
we all pull together we can bring all of
them home what do you say head down and
prepare the outpost she'll you'll be
fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good timing thanks for guiding his home
commander
[Music]